JOE KRUTEL: I just had
the weirdest dream last night.
That our business cratered.
(IMITATES EXPLOSION)
JESSE: That wasn't a dream...
and the meteor
was a wrecking ball named Lance.
SPENCER STRASMORE: Which is why
I'm rebranding Sports X
and we're gonna pivot
back to football.
♪ Kill the lights
We gonna play in the dark ♪
♪ Draggin' the chains
And makin' the spark ♪
The organization
hasn't forgotten about you.
I'm ready to give my life
on that field.
Who's sacrificing for me
besides my mom?
What are you sacrificing?
I wanna get paid.
♪ We know the rules ♪
JOE:
These guys have authenticity.
♪ We won't ever stop
We won't ever rest ♪
Everything we do
is straight up nasty.
JOE: We make bank
and keep it real.
(IMITATES SHOTGUN)
I like that! Uncle Fester
came to play today, okay!
SPENCER: The greatest athlete
on the planet
is gonna shock the world.
MAN: The kid stays.
And if not,
we're coming for you.
And everything you got
your dirty little hands in.
The whole system is a scam!
Please don't tell me
that you've decided
to take on
one of the most corrupt
and powerful organizations
in all of sports.
I did.
♪ Savage ♪
♪ Busting the cabbage ♪